hello everyone and welcome to today's
live webinar new get Co b27 + neuronal
cultures system next-generation media
for superior neuronal survival and
functionality presented by dr. Joe core
a senior staff scientist at Thermo
Fisher Scientific I'm Cindy Valdez and
I'll be your moderator for today's
educational webinar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by thermo Fisher
Scientific before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that
green Q&A button located at the lower
left of your presentation window type
the question into the box that appears
on the screen and I'll answer as many as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation also notice that you're
viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on the screen icon located on the lower
right if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation use the support
button at the top right or use the Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem good news during the
presentation audience members will have
an opportunity to answer a few polls
that will guide our presenter during her
discussion we appreciate your
participation so what's all further ado
I'd like to now introduce today's
speaker dr. Bob joke or dr. Corr is a
senior staff scientist at Thermo Fisher
Scientific in the cell biology business
based in Frederick Maryland she is part
of a team focusing on research
development and commercialization of
next-generation tools and reagents of
Neurobiology stem cell culture and
differentiation she has served as an R&D
lead for launch of over eat new products
in the market spanning neurobiology
cryopreservation and stem cell
differentiation areas dr. Corr is
developed and utilized a range of
research tools including media
formulation optimization verification
and validation process development of
standard
QC assays technology transfer
manufacturing protocols experimental
design and statistical analysis prior to
starting at Thermo Fisher Scientific in
2007 as a scientist she joins University
at Buffalo New York as a postdoctoral
fellow and published more than 20
research articles in peer-reviewed
journals in the field of Neurobiology
cell signaling and protein biochemistry
please join me in welcoming dr. Cora I
will now turn the presentation over to
her welcome dr. Corr thanks for the
introduction to the hello everybody
today I'm going to talk about a product
we recently launched and we are very
excited about is get Cobie 27 plus
neuronal culture system which is a
next-generation media for superior
neuronal survival and functionality this
is a cmp neuronal culture system
comprised of b27 plus supplement and
your Basel class media that we lively
enables the highest survival of primary
in human stem cells derived neurons
if you have ever used neurons ever
cultured neurons you must have used b27
neuro basal or b27 light culture system
this p27 class system is derived from
that system but it enables better and
superior performance in its snapshot you
see on the left side of the image which
you see is Mouse cortical neurons
cultured in neuro basal b27
and on right-hand side you see cells
cultured in your basal plus B 27 class
culture system you see very healthy
superior quality of neural cultures in B
20 sound system and I want to show you
this video this is a time-lapse
microscopy of two weeks cultures of
primary Mouse cortical neurons on left
hand side you see b27 neuro basis or
classic system and on right inside you
see B 27 plus system what you see here
the higher number of cells surviving
fast Nurik out growth and overall
cultures look very healthy and very good
noodle new rate network so the standard
in this mineral culture just got better
v27 + neuronal culture system has a
basal media which is 1x basal media and
a 50x supplement these two are validated
to work together but can be purchased
individually
also if you need but individual medium
and supplement can still be used with
other available medium supplements
meaning b27 plus supplement can be used
with classical Neo basil and neuro basal
plus can be used with classic b27 but to
achieve the maximum benefit of the
system using the class system together
is recommended in the system can
seamlessly replace other systems such as
neo basil d-27 without any change in the
current workflow this system is
recommended for the maintenance of
primary rat mouse and human PSE derived
and fetal derived neurons and also for
the differentiation of human PSE derived
and fetal derived NS ease to neurons
this system is not recommended to be
used in expansion or proliferation of
the cells so the key benefits of this
media system are the highest survival of
primary and stem cell derived neurons we
have validated the system to provide 50%
higher neuronal survival at 14 days and
beyond compare to our classical classic
projects and this proves to be the
highest in industry and you have already
seen the video it provides the
accelerated and increased new write out
growth in the cultures and not only just
a more quality and
you write out growth the neurons show
improved functionality and maturation
and I will show you the data for each of
these benefits so what has changed as
compared to our classic be 27 and your
basal system these are optimized
formulation votes from derived from your
basal and be 27 with this is optimized
to achieve the maximum neuronal survival
and the best performance without adding
any small molecules or growth factors
also the manufacturing process has been
upgraded and acceptance criteria the
specifications for the raw materials and
the final products have been tighter so
the acceptance criteria has also been
upgraded so I'm going to show some data
on survival of primary and stem cells
derived murals so the thirty-seventh
trust system is validated to provide 50%
more rad cortical neurons as compared to
be 27
so the validation means that we used at
least three different lots of these
system and at least three operators
conducted separate experiments in
multiple runs and we consistently showed
50% higher neuronal survival in rat
cortical neurons and these are the
images of primary rad cortical neurons
cultured in neuro basal b27 the top
panel and B 27 plus neo basal plus at
the bottom panel so the cells are
cultured ontology lies in coated plates
for 20 days and cells are fixed at
various time for a day 7 day 14 day 21
and then they are stained for neuronal
markers and here they are staying for
map 2 and counterstain for daddy
so the outer panels show the images from
b27 cultures you can see that the cells
don't survive for long
where as in vitro a7 plus system shown
in
the bottom panel does have very healthy
network and very high survival rate you
can see still see a day for at 14 days
two weeks and three weeks so you can get
more benefits of the system when you
culture these neurons for longer
durations so very clearly you see much
healthier on neuronal culture in b27
plus and your basal class system even at
longer duration of the cultures so not
only in rad cortical neurons we
validated the system in red cortical
neurons but we also demonstrated the
higher neuronal survival in other cell
systems like primary mouse cortical
neurons rad cortical neurons I already
talked about rat hippocampal neurons and
human eye PFC derived neurons cells
which were cultured in be 27 or be 27
plus system and stained with map to QC
hoody and counter stained with nappy I'm
just going to mention a little bit about
these antibodies Matthew is a
microtubule marker staining soma and all
the dendrites which is very commonly
used neuronal marker you see judy is not
routinely used but it is a neuronal
marker which binds to the neuronal RNA
staining just a cell body making it very
convenient for researchers to count
cells so this really helped us to
quantitate the neuronal number neuronal
survival data and we use cell cell
inside cx5 phenomics to quantitate the
data in these images visually you can
see that the b27 plus system you get
superior cultures across multiple
species and neuronal cell types so this
slide shows the quantitation of the data
I just showed of neuronal number just in
B 27 verses D 27 plus systems in each
system of mouse and rat and human IPS
you see that you don't know survival in
multiple species to various extend it is
different it extends differently but
definitely the effect or the benefit of
b27
plus is superior in vitro descent
classes compared to be 27 and we also
demonstrated that the cell cultured in
alternate commercially available media
other than be 27 or be 27 plus system if
be 27 + showed the best performance in
terms of the highest neuronal survival
in multiple cell types which I already
mentioned so in addition to the
maintenance of neuronal cultures be 27
plus has the advantage in neuronal
differentiation also in these experiment
neural stem cells and SES was derived
from h9 human embroiling stem cells by
give Co PSE neural induction media new
media they were expanded energies were
expanded and then they were plated and
polity lies in lemon in double coded
plays and treated with culture one
supplement that's also a gift ko
supplement a new write land first
quantified with inca site zoo at three
weeks after differentiation after
culturing for 3 weeks
cells were stained with map 2 when Hugh
CD and the grass on right show the
better new right out growth and better
survival of differentiated neurons and
similarly we got similar results in seed
of derived energy is also in feed of
derive energy needle-nosed
differentiation there was impulsive
improvement in both new rate outward and
neuronal number another benefit of using
d-27 class system is that you can
culture the neurons at a low density
journey
low density culture don't last very long
and it's not really even easy to culture
low density neurons and some cells like
finicky cells like Mouse cortical
neurons which are not easy to culture
especially in classic systems this media
is very robust but and then it can
support the low density culture and also
the high density Omni Donal cultures you
actually see better improvement over b27
in low density cultures so this is a
very good advantage that if you have if
you don't have a lot of cells and the
quality of the cells is really required
so you can use this media system to
culture yourselves with good yield so
here is just a compatibility and the
effect of b27 plus system-wide do they
need to be used together meaning why
near basel plus and b27 plus need to be
used together because you see a
synergistic effect the last bar shows if
you use neo basil class and b27 plus
together you see the maximum neuronal
survival but b27 plus supplement can
also be used with other media like Nero
basil and vice versa
meaning Nero gains old plus medium can
also be used with classic b27
but you will not see the maximum effect
which we want to see which you can
actually see with Nero basil class and
v-27 truck systems so this media also
shows excavated and increased new write
out growth which you have already seen
in the video which I just showed you and
here is the quantitative data from the
new write out growth from Noons and we
used as an insight from phase contrast
images the data is collected from that
and images were taken at various time
points overall you see that all new
write out growth is higher in b27 plus
sister
and you start seeing the benefit of this
system even at week one it's right
inside data shows that new rate out
growth was highest in d-27 class system
as compared to the cells which were
cultured in alternative media system
even at week one next set of slides I
want to show some data on how this
system helps in better maturation and
functionality of neurons this data shows
that when you culture neurons in b27
plus system you get improved maturation
and these images if you look at them
very obvious these are the rat cortical
neurons which were cultured for 22 days
in either b27 system or v 27 plus system
and then the cells were stained with
dendritic
Marta tubules marker map 2 and Costain
with presynaptic marker synapse in' on
right hand side you see the connotation
of synaptic positive Punta Honduras you
see that there is improved neuronal
maturity and demonstrated by at least a
three-fold increase in the synaptic
staining and in the images you see very
healthy in mature network of B 27 plus
as compared to be 27 so I want to go and
talk about little bit about MEA
this is not something we routinely use
in our labs only this is used only for
the testing of physiological activity so
I just want to mention some little
introduction on this how we used it we
use axion bio system mes system we
played it RAC cortical neurons and 48
valve any a place and cultured for 35
days in different media which I will go
indeed
sails on next slide and we recorded
spontaneous electrophysiological
activity at two to four days intervals
at each time point we did three five
minutes recording when we look at the
spontaneous activity we look at the mean
fighting weight and bursting and the
spite weight is the number of spikes per
second and the data of journey which we
collected is the average of spite rate
from all the girls having the same media
conditions images on the left these are
the grades kind of bits of the
electrodes the activity is recorded from
neurons which are in contact with the
electrodes and we followed axion
instructions where high density plaited
is recommended so we played it at very
high density 80,000 cells life cells in
up on quality lies encoded NEA plays and
this is a kind of overview of how the
data is collected here is an example of
waveform of action potential being
recommend recorded and the image you see
here this panel is kind of spike train
from electrodes so sometimes there are
single spikes or sometimes there are
clusters or both and each cluster can
have variable number of spite and image
on right is the data from six electrodes
basically looking at the network format
to look at how the whole network is
firing as the newest mature better be
right out wrote better neuronal network
is formed so you would expect a healthy
culture and more any activity and more
synchronized burst and in volume you see
an example of the data in power output
this is a raster plot of 16 electrodes
showing bursts from each electrode
The Fault in electro where I put the
arrow on is the number of spikes per
left out of 38 so a lot of spikes in
single bus so you increase you can
increase the resolution and just to show
that how these armed spite and these can
be differentiated and we use axiom
software to do all these analysis so for
our experiments we compared spontaneous
activity from neurons cultured in
classic be twenty sevens be 27 plus
system and ranges which is this is a
commercially available medium designed
for electrophysiological studies and we
found that range phase medium increased
the spike rate at early time points and
peaks at day ten or so and stays up a
day 14
but then drops off a day 17
whereas b27 blood system you can see
that it starts increasing gradually but
it stays up a day to day one and stays
consistent for up to at least day toriel
35 and on here on right hand side these
are the raster plots of spontaneous
activity 60 seconds in different media
systems at the point of their peak spike
rates
so for B 27 plus and B 27 we did day 21
and for vein fills the activity was
peaked at day 10
so these are the rest rested flocks of
that in brain fills a day 10 of in spite
rate is the highest in the media the
bursting is not synchronized and is
inconsistent where as you see in be 27
system the bursting is very synchronized
and it is consistent over time and it is
very rhythmic so overall it shows that
the advantage of B 27 plus is
in MEA especially for the screening or
the drug treatment studies there is a
consistent low background which makes it
very easy to tell the difference if you
are looking at the response or even like
a light or little response of various
drugs
so overall b27 cloud system is those
inconsistent stable and highly
synchronized spontaneous activity over
time which enables the lobe a drunk
system with increased sensitivity and
the simplified analysis of m en i want
to talk a little about glial cell
suppression in primary neuronal cultures
with the culture one supplement because
in primary neuronal cultures having
glial cells is a common issue sometimes
they can be undesired because you don't
want too many of them so with culture
one you can actually control the
quantities of exercise and [ __ ]
identified these are just some three
examples from various cultures showing
different quantities of exercise which
are stained with gfa P in red and bottom
oligodendrocytes which are stained with
gal C antibodies in green you see
various amounts of glial cells present
and that can depend on various media
systems time of isolation of neurons and
the quality of the starting cell
population so with culture one
supplement you can control the levels of
astrocytes by adding culture one
supplement to get complete suppression
you can include it add a zero or day two
and you can find you their suicide
presence by delaying the addition of
culture one so but overall you can fine
tune the astrocytes levels in your
family neuronal cultures similarly only
good exercise believe identified growth
can be controlled with culture one
supplement but
it cannot be fine [ __ ] we didn't see
that if you can fine tune that negated
oligodendrocytes presents with culture
ones but it will suppress the presence
of oligodendrocytes so if you add it at
time of plating you can get complete
suppression but we didn't see any
partial suppression or fine-tuning with
oligodendrocytes and here is the data
showing that even when you are getting
the suppression of glial cells exercise
and oligodendrocyte there is no effect
on neuronal culture morphology or the
number of neurons is barely changed so
here is the ordering information for b27
+ neuronal culture system which can be
bought together and all they can be
bought individually as b27 class
supplement and neuro basil class medium
so in summary um is this B 27 + neuronal
culture system enabled the highest
survival of primary and human stem cells
derived needles it accelerates and
improves new right out roads maturation
and functionality and it controls and
suppresses BL cell growth with culture
one supplement in primary internal
cultures and seamlessly replaces culture
of current supplement and media and
protocols used to maintain mature or
differentiate the neurons with that I
would like to thank the B 27 + neuronal
culture system team who all participated
in developing the formulation and
generating the application data thank
you everyone for your attention and I
will be happy to take any questions
wonderful thank you so much dr. Corr for
that informative presentation and your
important research we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions audience members
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click the send
button will answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's take a look at
our first audience members
our first set of questions is will you
be discontinuing the current b27
supplement and neuro diesel medium no we
will not be discounted
continuing near basel and b27 which are
our current products but will of course
offer neuro basel plus and B 27 plus
those are the new products thank you so
much dr. Corr here's our next question
from our audience members can you use
the B 27 plus systems for NSCs
yes I showed some data around that - we
can use our v-27 class system for NFC's
you can use this for NSC differentiation
basically you can replace classic b27
system but you won't be getting any
advantage if you are using it for NSE
expansion so we don't recommend for
expansion but we will still continue to
recommend stem probe NSE sfm or new
expansion media which urban tennessee's
are induced from IDS's so we will still
keep on recommending those but not this
new v-27 class system for NSC expansion
wonderful thank you and i want to thank
our audience members we have some
wonderful questions coming in you love
your active participation our next
question is how long have you cultured
neurons for with the be 27 plus system
we have cultured these vehicle to wrap
neurons for at least seven weeks
multiple times and we haven't tried to
culture it longer but I think if you
keep on feeding the cells regularly you
can keep the culture going even longer
thank you again is the lot a lot
variability of b27
plus less than that of the regular b27
yes because we have actually modified or
qualifying assays for both near basel
class and b 27 plus and we have optimum
you know the specification range for
some of the passing criteria for example
osmolarity has been tightened and
specially for d 27 plus we have modified
the essays to have more stringent
passing criteria and not only for the
finished goods not only for the final
product but also the incoming raw
material which go in the formulation the
acceptance criteria has been very much
controlled so we will see better lot
consistency in our new system thank you
and here's a related question dr. Corr
from an audience member across the
country how have you improved the lock
to lock consistency of the b27 plus and
the neuro basel plus products I think
it's related in I already mentioned we
have in all the raw material which goes
into these formulations that has been
control there is a acceptance criteria
for raw material that has been tightened
and so so is the final product so we
there will be no inconsistent performing
tada going out to the market wonderful
thank you and what is the performance of
neuro Basel regular with B 27 plus
compared to the neuro bezel plus and B
27 plus together okay I showed that data
already but let me go back and see here
so minimum I already mentioned that near
basel b27
you will just get does you know the
usual performance when you get near
basel plus into the mix instead of neuro
basel you will see slightly higher
performance but the most benefits you
will get when you use near basel plus
and b37 to us together here's our next
question from our audience numbers could
the be 27 plus media be used to assess
neurite outgrowth with neuro trophic
growth factors I mean you can culture
these cells where you have V 27 plus
system and you will get better new right
outwards with this system as compared to
our classic neo base will be 27 system
great thank you
hmm I love our
we have so many questions coming in we
really appreciate the participation how
many times was the MEA
X experiment repeated okay I think the
data which I showed here is from at
least of course it's for fun experiment
but we have repeated this experiment at
least three times showing consistent
data consistent results okay and what is
the source of the HUC backwash D
antibody our thermo Fisher
Thermo Fisher Scientific I think I have
the Catalans catalog number also here in
nine note it is a two one two seven one
and you can order it from thermo Fisher
online named dr. Cora and how has
culture one used with this product
okay so culture one is used at multiple
for multiple cell types here for primary
neurons we use culture one if when we
see a lot of glial cells which you will
expect with new new visibly 27 class
system and addition of culture one will
reduce or you can fine-tune the glial
cells the data I have already shown and
also in human NFC or fetal data a human
NSE derived NFC differentiation you can
use culture one and you will see very
less proliferating cells in NSE
differentiated neurons if you just for
that I would add a little bit more to
that you will have to optimize the cell
density for IPS II derived NS ease
because once you have culture one they
might get over crowded so the density
which we recommend for IPS see derived
neurons when you are using V 27 plus
with recommended concentration of
culture one less than 40,000 cells live
cells per centimeter square and for
fetal derived neurons it
fifty thousand cells per centimeter
secure thank you so much
here's our final question from our
audience and again I want to thank the
audience for being so actively
participant in this webinar there's a
b27 plus increase the transmission
efficiency in primary neuronal cultures
I would expect so but we have not tested
that so far yet thank you and dr. Carr
would you like to provide any closing
remarks before the audience before we
close today yeah just one thing you know
I have been using your base of d-27 for
a long time since you know two of my
neural biology culture and we are really
excited to see whenever we see data are
generated in your basal b27
plus system the cultures look great so I
would just say it's again that go ahead
order the free samples which are
available online once you tell them you
will be really happy to see the results
wonderful thank you dr. Corr for your
presentation I'd also like to thank lab
roots and thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible for more information please
visit our webpage at thermo Fisher comm
front slash b27 plus to learn more about
Thermo Fisher Scientific before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April 2018 you will
receive an email from rad roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye
you